uh my name's eugene uh i'm a berkeley
phd student uh i'm starting as a
professor at nyu and i'm currently at
fair so some of this work is going to be
from berkeley uh
at berkeley fair and some of it is going
to be work from deep mind which i
actually did with raphael so
it's a wonderful coincidence
uh and yeah the talk is about going to
be about learning social norms in
decentralized settings
so uh the kind of the context uh that i
am coming at this from is that we are
kind of living in a world where we are
starting to see lots of deployed
multi-agent systems um and this this
feels a little weird sometimes in the
sense that you know we don't see
lots of deployed ai everywhere but from
kind of the the transportation
perspective of things we're starting to
see
uh you know uh drones that are deployed
for uh like wildfire monitoring or flash
flood detection
um and if you kind of zoom out a little
bit you can think of
uh you know apple maps and google maps
as
uh multi-agent systems that are
interacting with each other in weird
ways
and particularly with respect to say
something like apple maps
we need the development of norms to
achieve a
desired cooperative outcome uh because
in the pr if they kind of free ride and
and operate separately and don't
coordinate in any way uh you can get
really bad outcomes uh so over here on
the right this is not actually an
instance of something that happens
because of apple maps and google maps
kind of fighting it out with each other
but conceptually it's something that
could happen uh so kind of in 27 2018
there's this big spurt of
towns getting very upset
because mapping systems would reroute
all of traffic through their town there
was this little town in new jersey
fairlawn uh where they were having
a town of like i don't know five
thousand ten thousand people that was
having two hour long traffic jams
uh because google mouse is routing like
everyone through them
um and so that what happened here is not
competition between uh two different
mapping systems but you could
conceivably imagine
uh
a lack of coordination between two
different mapping systems uh pushing too
much traffic through one place leading
to this type of congestion
um and you know as as apple maps becomes
better because it sucked in 2018
uh don't quote me on that
you might see the sort of things start
to emerge
um and and
um sort of as a car person uh this is we
we also are going to have these systems
operating in settings that have existing
norms that we're going to need our
systems to be able to adopt and interact
with
so if you drive a frequent thing that
you will observe when there is a very
crowded exit is someone will move out of
the exit lane and then they like they'll
attempt to free ride and like go down
one of the fast open lanes and then try
to re-enter to the exit lane right at
the end and sometimes you will see
people punish the defectors by not
letting them into the lane
um
so we're you know we're starting to
deploy autonomous systems in settings
that have existing norms that need to
acquire uh cooperative outcomes
um that are likely to be decentralized
because you're not going to get apple
and google maps to coordinate together
and share data together
uh so i'm going to talk a lot about
social norms so i want to start by like
giving an operative definition that i'm
going to work with
uh just to sort of ground the thing so
i'm going to say that something is a
social norm if it is a collective
established pattern of approval and
disapproval that is so we have a stable
equilibrium
where deviation from that equilibrium is
specifically uh sanctioned so if you try
to move away it's not that it's just
like disadvantageous for you someone is
going to go out of your way to punish
you for deviating from that equilibrium
um with things this does not include it
does not give us a preference over
equilibria it does not allow we're not
distinguishing between good and bad
equilibria uh and i don't particularly
care about what type of equilibrium
concept we're talking about
so nash correlated we're all good yeah
uh this what's space
uh
yeah it's it's in the the the joint
policies they're all they're all at
some sort of equilibrium together
um okay so uh i'm gonna talk about
mostly is this paper uh a learning agent
that acquires social norms from public
sanctions in decentralized multi-agent
settings uh which i did an internship at
deepmind uh with raphael and uh joel
lippo who were hosting me there
um so the underlying goal is uh to both
to study the emergence of norms but also
how to endow our agents with kind of a
norm learning process you know what do
we need to
add to our systems to get our agents to
learn norms and what do we need to do
that to get them to learn norms in a
fully decentralized way
[Music]
and so when we think about
decentralized norm learning and
decentralized norm learning that might
be deployed into a real world system
we need to think about what type of
signals are available uh for real world
norm learning and this is kind of
distinct from uh many kind of
multi-agent rl settings um kind of the
dominant framework for
uh successful learning of multi-agent rl
policies assumes some type of
centralization whether it's uh
uh scheduling of the order agents play
with each other or sharing of
observations or rewards or so on uh and
as you look at kind of real-world
systems some of these assumptions are
hard to
uh believe are realistic right so if we
think about sharing of rewards or cost
functions uh av companies will not share
their cost functions with each other
this is like the secret sauce
um
and when we move away from these fully
cooperative settings to mixed motive
settings you kind of get the potential
of something like utility monster where
we say i'm gonna share my reward with
you i give you a nonsense reward that
you know pushes you towards the
equilibrium that i want
um policies uh which are always which
sharing policy is a big part of of you
know moral
uh policies are generally secret or if
we're operating systems with humans we
do not even know what the policy is
and just sharing observations is
probably insufficient for
coordination that's just a claim i'm
going to make
though it might be fine if you can
somehow do irl from just observations
alone
um
so we're going to propose
what we think is like a more compatible
framework for learning
in these settings which is learning from
public sanctions
so we're going to assume that there is
some kind of known sanctioning action in
the world that are inherently
displeasing to the agents so if we think
about cars it might be honks or
aggression
and these sanctioning schemes can often
be introduced without necessarily
revealing private information right so
we can be moving in the world we see an
agent honk at another agent and we're
like that's a sanction let's store that
for for our
uh you know for our learning procedure
so it can be government initiation
company initiated it can just be learned
by moving through the world
um
and so yeah there's a couple frameworks
we might think about doing this like
sanctioning learning so in the one i
mentioned you might learn sanctions
through
uh
get these sanctioned observations
through through averaging you're just
moving around the world every time you
see another agent you take it you stored
your buffer you remember that you saw
that happen
and we're gonna use that information to
learn or you could imagine there's some
kind of like replay buffer that we're
all storing every sanction we all saw
together like every time we sanction
anytime we see a sanction we push in the
replay buffer every agent can do that
and you can think of this kind of like a
um
like a you go to the you go to a given
city and there's like a glossary of all
the sanctions that ever happened there
and you can like try to learn the norms
of that city from that that glossary
um
uh so
okay so we're gonna try to learn social
norms through public sanctions um and
we're gonna make a couple assumptions on
our models of norm learning uh this is a
model uh you could come up with other
models uh and this model has
flaws and strengths uh we're going to
assume that agents have their own
internal model some kind of like
cognitive model of norms
uh they're going to learn those norms
through the observed disapprovals
and they're going to have a weak
inherent preference for obeying those
norms so they've learned some they go
out in the world they see sanctions uh
they learn
how what others believe to be a
sanctioning event
and they slightly desire to sanction the
same way that everyone else sanctions
uh and so we propose an architecture
called classifier norm learning or i'm
gonna call that cnm throughout the talk
uh so we're gonna
uh
live in that kind of buffer model of
observing sanctions uh where um every
time an agent
sees another agent it knows whether or
not it has a sanctioning opportunity so
some some i'll go into the specifics of
the environment in a second uh every
time there is a sanction or a
non-sanction it is passed to a buffer
stored and agents can use that to learn
and they're going to take those sanction
and non-sanctioning events uh and
they're going to use them to train a
classifier that predicts the probability
of a sanction occurring given some
context and the current observation
uh and so we're gonna have a classifier
and a policyhead the classifier will
predict the probability of a sanction
that's going to be concated into the
policy at some internal layer
and then that's uh so the policy is able
to condition his choices on that that
sanction probability
and then we're going to slightly reward
the agent for uh punishing in accord
with the classifier so sanctioning
accord with the classifier and slightly
penalize it for if it sanctions and the
classifier said not to sanction
um
and i'm just gonna skip that real quick
um so how does this shape learning
um so like why why why is this going to
like cause us to learn norms really
quick so when the agents start off in
the world there's some initial asymmetry
in the punishing behavior
the classifier latches on to that
initial asymmetry
and you are rewarded for following along
with that initial asymmetry so there's
going to be some behavior that happens
to be disapproved
you're going to be slightly pushed
towards disapproving of that behavior
more than other behaviors the frequency
of that behavior will go down
and it's just going to kind of reinforce
itself
and so this this
um
this kind of reinforcement procedure is
mostly a reward agnostic it's like
slightly reward agnostic and that that
initial exploration distribution that
that pushes you in a direction is
influenced by the reward
but once it starts going it's more about
whatever the classifier says you should
be doing once we get the ball rolling
uh so we're gonna you know uh now that
we've put together our model of how
norms learn we're gonna ask does this
architecture enable us to learn norms
will the norms that come out be
beneficial and you know what can we get
into some of the mechanistic details of
how the norms actually shape the
learning and push us towards towards an
equilibrium
the environment we're going to use for
this is a mixed kind of
mixed motive environment in melting pot
which is a
suite of kind of
uh
kind of challenging
uh multi-agent problems released by
deepine uh it's called allelopathic
harvest so we have this big open world
with i think like 16 agents in it and
the world is full of berries that have a
particular color
and agents can go around and they can
recolor the berry any color that they
want
and the berry growth is linear in the
berry fraction so if there are lots of
red berries red berries are going to
grow really fast so these are these are
berry planting berry sites and berries
grow on those sites you color the sites
and berry grows on the site
and so
uh if you can get the the berry sites to
like a mono color uh a single color
you're going to get lots of berries
everyone's going to be happy there's
going to be tons of berries for everyone
to eat
and the agents have a preference for
either
red berries or green berries
if the whole world is red they're happy
if the whole world is green they're
happy
if the whole
all the berries are blue they are not
quite so happy they have an intrinsic
preference to eat red and green berries
they love them
um
and this game also has ubiquitous
opportunities for sanctioning so the
agents have a zapping beam they can zap
every four steps
um the zaps the first time they zap them
they freeze the agent the second time
they remove them from the system and
they're reinserted some 50 steps later
and these apps have two functions so one
they can serve as sources of normative
sanctioning to say i disapprove of your
action
they also have a functional purpose so
you may be competing with another agent
over berry you freeze them
and then you can steal the berry while
they're frozen
uh so so it kind of mixes mixes these
two things together
um and i'm gonna say our equilibrium
concept in quotes because you know can't
really prove that it's an equilibrium uh
is uh that we get a stable berry
fraction across across episodes and we
get a stable distribution of zap colors
so they converge to a monocul something
close to monoculture and they tend to
punish kind of a consistent set of
things
um okay so we run this process forward
we turn on the classifier we had a very
small reward for obeying the classifier
a very small penalty for disobeying the
classifier
and i think the first thing that you can
kind of see this reinforce reinforce
this kind of like ball rolling process
uh is if you look at the predictions of
the classifier so we have um
uh two settings i think the the real
thing to look at is just like ignore
this blue curve let's look at the green
curve and the orange curve
so the the green curve is the classifier
on
uh the
orange curve is the classifier is
training but it's not being used to
generate rewards
and what you can see is that the when
you uh
are rewarding for obeying the classifier
the classifier rapidly
causes behaviors to be predictable by
the classifier
so it immediately
uh you know generates behavior that's
consistent with itself
um and and you know if you don't have
the rewards eventually it does learn to
predict when agents punish or don't
punish that's mostly when they're
fighting over a berry
uh but it doesn't quite have this like
process of like zooming toward them
towards a consistent punishment behavior
uh and we can also
uh kind of see this uh reinforcement
process uh happening if we look at the
distribution of barrier fractions so
here we have a simplex representing the
distribution of areas in the system
on the left we have the system with no
classifier on the right we have the
system with the classifier and what you
can see is that the presence of the
classifier pushes you
towards uh the different kind of uh
vertices of that simplex
and it also has this property of as i
mentioned sort of being reward agnostic
so agents are pushed to the blueberries
even though they have no particular
preference for the blueberries because
in the initial exploration distribution
sometimes agents get punished for being
green and red a bit more so they learn
to become blue
they don't want to be but
that's what happens sometimes you get a
norm you don't want
um
so and you know towards this point of
you know i said our equilibrium concept
was going to be moving towards a
monoculture uh we see that if we have
the classifier on that's the blue curve
versus having the classifier off that's
the orange curve the
and the the y-axis is the the the
fraction of berries that are
one color
um
we see that there's we're moving we're
moved much more towards the monoculture
kind of consistent with what the the
simplicities that we saw
um so the second question i said so
norms are things where you are punished
for deviating from the um
from the equilibrium
and one thing we can view the learning
as is kind of doing some kind of
internal hypothesis testing right so uh
the agent
is running around it's being zapped
uh and it can ask itself
what color is safer so if we look at the
ratio of zap likelihood so probability
of zap given a color
and we look at the difference between
your zap likelihood if you're free
riding which is just running around
eating berries
this is my mistake if you run around and
eat berries you become gray so the
agents know who is free riding they can
see who's free riding
so there's a gray color in addition to
the other colors
um so
if you uh if you're running around free
riding when the classifier is on
your likelihood of being zapped given
gray is greater than your likelihood of
being zapped if you are
uh the color of the berry that you are
coloring
uh sorry this is again my mistake if you
color a berry red you become red so
agents can see what you've been coloring
or if you've been free riding
so
if you
if the monoculture is if if we're moving
towards a monoculture red and you're
going around and coloring red berries
instead of free riding you are less
likely to be zapped the agents observe
that they
stop free riding they you know uh start
doing the right thing
and similarly there's also you can look
at the the zap likelihood between the
dominant color and the second dominant
color
and when
the classifier is on there is a sharper
difference in the zap likelihood so it's
easy for the agent to observe that i
should be not only not be free writing i
should not be trying to color berries
green instead of red or red instead of
green
um
so last thing
are the norms beneficial
so sanctioning comes with costs when you
are sanctioning you are not eating
berries which is your favorite activity
um so if we look at the collective
return and compare it in the system with
and without sanctions
uh the collective return has gone up
despite time lost to doing the
sanctioning behavior and also a reward
that was lost due to the penalty that
comes with getting sanctioned
um i want to kind of maybe end with a
couple interesting oddities and open
questions that i think remain in this
work
um
so one
totally open we assume that we know what
the sanctions are right i sat down and i
said sanctioning is when you get zapped
right but in the world we do have some
models of what we feel is a sanction but
they're not you know quite defined in
this way so how can we remove this and
and make it a little less user-defined
behavior
there's a second thing that i want to
mention that is we found to be kind of
interesting uh so
we have three experiments here so in
green we have the cnm experiment in red
we have no classifier and in yellow we
have a classifier um
that we continue training throughout the
whole training in the green in the
normal case we freeze the classifier
after some 100 million steps
and the reason we do this
is because if we do not do this
a norm will emerge pretty quickly on the
the reward will spike up and then the
norm will be unlearned
um and the reason
we believe that this happens is because
the norms are learned by observation
so
once the behavior is suppressed you stop
seeing examples
of
uh the the norm
of agents being punished for violating
the norm uh and so the classifier
rapidly unlearns the norm
uh and maybe this isn't real world and
interesting property of norm learning
that
uh once once a norm has been established
and it suppresses the behavior that it
was intended to suppress everyone
forgets why it was there and the norm
disappears maybe it's a weird property
of our model but i think it's uh you
know just
sort of interesting
um okay so i want to end uh by talking a
little bit about some work we've been
doing at fair about how we sort of start
moving from these kind of grid worlds uh
to studying real world norms
which i think requires some amount of
uh working with real data for you know
starting to understand how human norms
are shaped and what human norms are and
so on and so forth
um
coming from sort of
the driving community uh one thing that
has become true in the past couple years
is that there is immense amounts of
human driving data that is available uh
like hundreds and thousands of hours uh
tens of thousands of hours
um so in some joint work with nathan
lisle at berkeley uh chao myang at fair
brandon amos and jacob forster
we have been working on that is out of
order
on nocturne which is a new data-driven
multi-agent benchmark that we are
releasing in about a week or so
uh it consists of a hundred thirty
thousand uh ten-second scenes uh taken
from wemo data
you have 450 000 if you include traffic
lights but we don't for some reasons i
can get into it contains lots of
complicated mixed motive situations uh
where agents would like to get to their
goal but they have interfering uh paths
from other agents and they need to
coordinate with them in some way so we
have like four-way stops emerging
vehicles um unprotected left turns and
like really complex parking lots and
another piece of this that is like
uh yeah and so it contains you know
these really complicated kind of
coordinated intersections where agents
have
conflicting paths and they need to move
in such a way that they don't collide
with each other and and they need to
reason about what the other agent sees
what its goal is
um what it's trying to signal to it
[Music]
and one thing that i think is really fun
about it and that we put a lot of time
and effort into is the agent has an
extremely partially observed scene
so on the left we have this like agent
moving along and on the right we have
what the agent sees as it moves
different agents obscure it it has to
kind of keep track of what's happening
and you know reason about the fact that
it's not able to like fully see the
scene
um
and so you know agents need to become
aware of the fact that you know uh if
they're driving up behind another agent
it does it just does not see them
um
another fun property of this benchmark
is that it we put a lot of effort into
making it fast you can get billions of
steps per day on a g1 gpu intensive use
which i think is important for
multiagent rl
which is extremely sample and efficient
and roughly 25 percent of those 130 000
scenes are extremely interactive or
mixed motive as defined by
uh agents need their trajectories to
cross each other in time
um
and yeah to finish off um kind of an
open some open questions that we hope we
can start investigating or maybe other
folks will investigate is how we can
start to characterize kind of the norms
and conventions in these scenes from the
expert data but also whether our
learning algorithms can learn
coordination and conventions and norms
of human quality
um which in kind of some preliminary uh
work we we've seen that they are not
able to um so here we have a graph of
the like the complexity of the scene so
the number of expert trajectories that
intersect in in a given scene
um and as we as there are more
intersections in the experts uh the
collision rate of like trained agents
that you might train with like some
multi-agent rl algorithm or some control
algorithm uh blows up uh so once once
you have a ton of intersecting paths uh
50 of the agents will collide
so yeah um thank you all very much uh if
you have any questions or if we're going
to the panel uh i appreciate you all
taking the time to listen to me
[Applause]
great thank you so much eugene uh do we
have any quick questions
before we start the panel
yeah
thanks for the talk especially on such
short notice um
the graph you showed where agents
unlearn a norm
because of continuous learning
um
i'm assuming that is uh like the norm
just kind of disappears and another one
doesn't spring up because they're not
it's not like they'll learn to hate red
berries or green berries but do you
think i know there's some work
uh like in the last few years on
emergent norm learning and just emergent
norms coming out of a multi-agent system
so
do you think that's a scenario where you
could learn a norm
unlearn it
and then another one would spring up and
some other interesting behavior could
happen yeah so uh so i want to be really
careful i gave up i gave it like a
speculative reason for why i think this
happens but i'm not confident that
that's the whole the whole story
um
but to your point so one one thing about
this environment is it like does not
have emergent norms like if you just
like run the agents forward they all
basically just learn to free ride
um
so maybe that's because of high feature
dimensionality like the algorithm's not
learning like maybe maybe the norm could
emerge anyways if we had better learning
algorithms and we wouldn't have to do
this but again who knows
and i think the reason that it doesn't
re-emerge afterwards is because this
kind of initial exploration asymmetry
has gone away they've learned to zap
solely for like instrumental reasons
um it's like a bunch of free riding
agents they're all grey they're running
around
um and the influence their ability to
zap each other just kind of goes down
like it as as the training distribution
as they continue training the number of
zaps drops off precipitously so there's
just like less
uh less maybe opportunity to zap or some
there's like something very special
about the initial exploration
distribution okay yeah yeah what do you
think would happen if you
like halfway through just
increased epsilon and they started
randomly taking actions again yeah i
think it'd probably come back okay cool
i mean that's how i bet